The location of particular values on the X axis is often described in terms of
standard deviations. Here you can see this is the mean, this is the mean plus
one standard deviation, this is the mean plus two standard deviations, and
likewise, this is the mean minus one standard deviation and minus two standard
deviations. Whatever score we might have, we can convert it to a value equal to
the number of standard deviations away from the mean. Let's call it z. By
converting scores in a normal distribution to this special number z. We can know
the percent less than or greater than that value. For example, if we find that a
value is one standard deviation away from the mean. Then no matter what normal
distribution we have. We know that approximately 84 percent are less than that
value. In the next lesson, you'll learn how to calculate the proportions less
than or greater than certain values in a normal distribution. What's an example
in which we might want to know the proportion less than or greater than a
particular number? Let's illustrate this with another story.